er sagte
300 300 tausend russische soldaten
bringen ich denke er wird sogar noch
mehr mobilisieren aber es sind keine
russische soldaten
wenn er kann einem menschen eine
information aber daraus wird kein soldat
er kann auch eine vogelscheuche auf ein
feld stellen und ihnen eine russische
uniform aber
gegen die ukraine können sie nichts
ausrichten
darum geht dass durch das russische volk
glaubt noch immer nicht daran dass es
ihm egal ist wie viele russen sterben
er möchte die ukraine im blut ertrinken
aber auch im blut seiner eigenen
soldaten
in seine rede putin hat mit atomwaffen
gedroht und hat gesagt dass es kein
bluff ist wie viele menschen sind
natürlich haben angst dass putin
tatsächlich dieser einsatz
ich glaube nicht dass er diese waffen
einsetzen wird
ich kann es sogar so formulieren ich
glaube nicht dass die welt es zulassen
wird
wir können
kopf von diesen menschen schauen es gibt
riesige ja aber wie soll das sein er
wird immer androhen atomwaffen
einzusetzen
und wie müssen unsere salze seine
wünsche erfüllen
wir können es nicht tun denn beim
nächsten mal wird er sagen kaufen sie
gas über diesen preis und er sagt nein
ich war dann liegt dann bei den
atomwaffen einsetzen ich muss später
wird er sagen wir haben jetzt die
ukraine eingenommen wir werden wir
wollen noch ein teil von kohlen haben
sonst werden wir atomwaffen einsetzen
wir können uns nicht auf
ein lassen es sind kompromissen
mitgerissen mit freiheit mit demokratie
mit dem völkerrecht das können wir nicht
tun die creme
zb haben menschen versucht zu vergessen
und dass die creme annektiert worden
aber putin hat später selbst erinnert
dass er dort kein halt macht
deshalb glaube ich nicht dass die welt
das zu lesen die atomwaffen einzusetzen
weiterhin ich glaube nicht daran dass
seine gesellschaft es ihnen erlaubt wir
müssen mit seinem gesellschaft arbeiten
alle staaten müssen zu dieser
gesellschaft sprechen samir scheuklappen
wegräumen
morgen sagen dass die komplette story um
der ukraine zu russland gehört und
übermorgen kann sagen dass lepra tischer
staaten estland polen viele
staaten er kann auch zu deutschland
sagen
und sagen ja auch deutschland hat ddr
und brd
ist früher war er wird sagen
entschuldigung wir werden beginnen die
mauer wieder aufzubauen
hier haben wir unser touristischen
ziegelsteine mitgebracht mit deutschland
sie darauf einlassen weil sie angst hat
dass russland atomwaffen einsetzt das
ist ein argument
der deutschen regierung dass es zu einer
eskalation kommt
bei all dem respekt die panzer werden
keinen punkt in diesem krieg setzen
unter kanzler muss es verstehen der
panzer technik bedeutet für uns das
überleben der ukraine der menschen hier
es geht auch nicht nur die fans als
gepanzerte fahrzeuge und diese technik
ist in deutschland voran und wir bieten
das zu bekommen
auch die luftabwehrsysteme ihre stil es
bedeutet nicht dass wir diesen krieg
gewinnen
es geht um das überleben unserer
menschen ohne luftabwehr werden mehr
menschen sterben
aber
keine waffe mit der sie gewinnen diese
waffen sind für uns sehr wichtig weil
die menschen lernen sind für uns sehr
wichtig aber wenn wir über die sieg
sprechen brauchen wir andere waffen
morgen wird im deutschen parlament
abgestimmt sie werden über kampfpanzer
abstimmen was ist ihre botschaft an die
deutschen politiker
[Musik]
es geht sehr viel darum
liefern ihre türen öffnen und damit
zeigen dass die idee ukraine panzer
geben und dann kann deutschland und
andere
ich möchte nicht an deutschland wende
und sagen sie sind unabhängig
von anderen staaten es ist ihre meinung
wenn sie bereit sind die menschen leben
bei uns
denn wir verteidigen unsere land gibt
uns diese warten sie sind ein
unabhängiger staat
wenn sie uns diese waffen nicht gegeben
beugen dann nichts für ungut sie haben
ihre meinung aber sagen redet dann
zuerst deutsch
jeder soll für sich selber verantwortung
übernehmen für uns bedeuten kampfpanzer
heute mehr menschenleben gerettet werden
aber ich möchte dass alle wissen dass
wir für unsere gemeinsame werte- kämpfen
und ich wünsche mir dass das unsere sieg
wird in ihrem früheren leben
herr präsident sie waren ein
komiker haben sie ein lieblingswitz über
putin
ich denke ja
ich bin nicht sicher dass ich bereit bin
diesen bisher zu erzählen
ganzes erzählen ich bin sicher ich denke
sie werden lachen und in russland werden
menschen weinen
ich bin mir sicher dass es angebracht
ist
sie können das schon sagen
es ist ein schwarzer humor
die letzte frage
wie sehen sie wütend auf deutsche
politiker schreien sie ab und zu
in richtung der deutschen politiker herr
scholz was ist passiert vielen dank
heute bringen sie ein gutes humor und
gute energie hier
ehrlich gesagt
und das liegt nicht nur an meinem
charakter
es spart die zeit um probleme zu lösen
das ist meine lebenseinstellung
scheint sie ab und zu ins telefon ja am
telefon war oft sehr direkt weil ich
bestimmte städte liegt verstanden habe
ich war genauso wie heute zu ihnen
sprechen ich sagte über die
milliardenschwere hilfe über die
luftabwehrsysteme die wir noch nicht
erhalten haben es wäre gut wenn sie bald
kommen
sie sprach
daten
und glücklich dass deutschland uns dabei
unterstützt habt und der koffer dass es
mit der folgt mitgliedschaft das gleiche
geschieht nicht mehr dem prozess sondern
mit dem ergebnis weiter prozess war sehr
kompliziert deshalb ja es gab
situationen wo hier die wände gezittert
ein mensch ist in einem fluss der
mensch getrimmt und schreit
und sie sind am ufer untermainstadt
helfen sie mir und am ufer
lautet die antwort warten sie die
abgeordneten müssen erst mal abstimmen
verstehen sie das ich verstehe das nicht
ich finde
wir müssen den menschen helfen ich wurde
selbst in den fluss gehen und den
menschen retten das wünsche ich mir von
bundeskanzler vom deutschen volk
ich kenne mich und ich weiß wenn etwas
passiert ja gut hörbar würde ich nicht
abstimmen ich wurde selbst hinlaufen und
treppen vielen dank herr präsident für
ihre zeit
[Musik]